je pense que si vous écoutez un petit
peu on a ce croustillant et donc tout à
la fois ce moelleux à l'intérieur ce qui
fait que pour moi c'est un croissant de
qualité avec l'industriel que vous
mangiez un croissant à nice à paris et
strasbourg où un race vous mangerez le
même avec le bout identique à mes yeux
le croissant est plus qu'importante
puisque c'est ce qui a déclenché il ya
deux ans ma démarche dont on avait parlé
sur brut puisque j'avais interpellé le
premier ministre sur la nécessité de
créer un label pour le croissant de la
même façon qu'on l'a fait pour la
baguette dite tradition et comme on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de 80% des
viennoiseries sur le marché qui sont
d'origine industrielle dans le pays de
la gastronomie
à mes yeux c'est honteux ne rien faire
c'est criminel c'est pas un combat d'un
jour c'est pas un seul combat c'est pas
mon premier combat et ça sera pas le
dernier
ce qui a changé depuis c'est de la prise
de conscience des français puisque
énormément de français ont commencé de
prendre conscience de cette invasion de
produits industriels donc demande de
plus en plus dans leur boulangerie est
ce que c'est du fait maison
là je suis en train de le rouler je sens
la douceur de la pâte
mais en même temps que je le roule je
suis en train de regarder la sur les
côtés si on se concentre bien on voit
les différentes couches de beurre
successives et de potes c'est un plaisir
parce que je sais déjà que ces trois
sont là demain ils vont affecter si tout
va bien il devrait être beau si je
faisais que sortir des croissants d'un
carton mais il aurait pu mon métier chez
un quincaillier et encore si je voudrais
pas manquer de respect aucun cahier je
serai plus qu'un marchand je serai plus
un artisan d'une manière générale ceux
qui fabriquent encore leurs produits
font énormément d'heures on est vraiment
au
et d'avoir une gamme un panel assez
large deux sortes de pain pour justement
que le client puisse faire un choix
maintenant c'est pas toujours évident
mais le client ne pouvant à ce jour
faire la différence entre un industriel
est un artisan c'est pas évident
puisqu'il ya pas de loi
on est obligé de faire de tous sinon on
serait déjà fermé en existerait déjà
plus
[Musique]
à
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que demain vous rentrez dans une
boulangerie on peut vous vendre des
croissants industrielle de la
viennoiserie industrielle de la
pâtisserie industrielle sans même avoir
à vous le mentionnez voire même en
allant plus loin vous sous-entendant que
c'est du fait maison pourquoi en ce
moment en sont ils arrivés là
alors certains sont découragés parce que
gagne plus bien leur vie parce que ce
faux pas faire de vue qu'un produit
industriel quand vous achetez un
croissant 15 centimes que vous le
revendez 1 euro vous fait énormément de
marche dessus
nous on les fabricants on a un coût de
production que déjà trois voire quatre
fois plus élevés lit un produit que j'ai
arrêté de vendre ce sont les chouquettes
souvent au monde demande mais quand j'en
ai à vendre j'ai du mal à les vendre
parce que je suis beaucoup plus cher que
mes concurrents qui les achètent
industriellement bien sûr et donc je
fais 30% plus chers et les clients nous
le reproche chaque jour 1b dit non vous
devez gagner beaucoup d'argent avec
l'ong choquette parce que vos voisins
sont 30% moins cher donc j'ai fini par
arrêter les chouquettes way
allez on va mettre en place des
croissants et des pains au chocolat pour
l'ouverture du miel vin que c'est
l'heure j'ai même deux minutes de retard
donc j'ai plus ce matin à 4 heures il
est maintenant 18h45 - 10 soit je dois
avoir trois minutes de retard
donc on va ouvrir jusqu'à ce soir 20h
avec juste une interruption d'une heure
entre deux et trois et ça va être du
mardi jusqu'au dimanche sur l'année qui
est passé moi j'ai eu un salaire net
d'environ 1200 euros pareil pour mon
épouse sachant que moi je suis à 80
heures par semaine minimum puisque
poitiers des périodes de fêtes on monte
à 90 ma femme fait pareil entre 70 75
heures par semaine il m'arrive souvent
de me poser la question pourquoi je
continue au vu du travail fourni par
rapport aux eur faite et au salaire que
j'en sors c'est déraisonnable quelque
part mais peut-être que j'aime trop mon
métier peut-être par fierté peut-être
parce que j'ai envie de me prouver
linverse d'y arriver est de mieux gagner
ma vie oui il ya certainement beaucoup
de fierté j'ai envie de réussir dans mon
métier et je pense que j'y arriverai
[Musique]